welcome to Horry subs the channel where
we discussed the latest tech news and
delve into newest tech products today
we're taking a look at whether you
should buy the GTX 10 atti or you should
wait for the gtx 1180 or AMD navi or
other things like that but before we
delve into make sure to hit that
subscribe button if you guys like to
stay updated with the latest tech news
related to gaming and pcs so if you guys
haven't noticed already a lot of GPUs
across the board are starting to hit
MSRP for example the EVGA gtx 1080 is
actually going for $550 right now which
is actually $50 less than MSRP and this
is actually true with other GPUs as well
for example the gtx 1080i while it
hasn't hit MSRP yet it's only $30 off at
730 dollars which is much better than
the 300 or $400 I was over MSRP just a
couple of months ago even the rx 580
series is now in the 200s so as you guys
can see GPU pricing is getting much
better but should you buy one especially
with how close the 1100 series is from
Nvidia well first of all I think we
should take a look at the expected
performance of the 1100 series because
if the performance isn't that good in
the first place then there really is no
point waiting for it so recently there
was this leak on techpowerup about the
specs of the gtx 1180 now I know that
there was a lot of controversy about the
numbers and how they are not accurate
however I think this is a good base and
it's probably a good estimate of what
the gtx 1180 will actually be like so
according to this leak the gtx 1180
should have 3584 cuda cores 224 TM use
and it should be on the 12 nanometer
process and consume more or less 200
watts if that did strike you as familiar
well then that's actually the almost the
exact same numbers as the gtx 980ti the
gtx 980ti also has 3584 cuda cores and
224 TM
use however the gtx 980ti is on the 60
nanometer process and it consumes 250
watts also yes gddr5 X memory instead of
the GDD r6 memory that is expected for
the gtx 1180 so on paper the gtx 1180 is
pretty much identical with the gtx 980ti
however it is a bit more efficient and
it's on a 12 nanometer process and it
should have GDD are six memory so those
little aspects should give it a little
performance edge over the gtx ten atti
but not too big so that's cool and all
but how will the other 1100 series cards
perform well last generation each card
improved its predecessor by about 2
levels so for example the 1060 was on
par with the 980 and the 1070 was pretty
much equal with the 980 TI unfortunately
this generation the generational gap
doesn't seem to be as big as last time
however it was to be very significant
for example with the leak that we had
the 1180 should be on par or a little
bit better than the gtx 1080i so from
that we can assume that the gtx 1170
will just barely be better or on par
with the 1080 and so on and so forth on
top of this all the gtx 1100 series
cards should have GT be our sixth memory
and beyond the 12 nanometer process so
that's a bonus as well next what about
price well in my opinion since the GPU
pricing situation has pretty much
leveled out and it's almost back to
where it was
I think these new cars will pretty much
release the same MSRP as their
predecessor so I think the gtx 1180 will
release for the same MSRP of $700 as the
GTX 1080 and as a result the GTX 1166
gigabyte card should be $250 and so on
and so forth so that's pretty good for
the same price you're pretty much
getting an extra
of GPU performance but what exactly are
these cards coming out well originally
these cards were expected and they are
still by a lot of people expected to
come on August
however Nvidia doesn't seem to be
dropping any hints about this and they
don't seem to be bringing out any news
at Computex either so that may not be
true however at the same time it has
been over two years since the 10th
series cards came out and on top of this
SK Hynix is going to be starting their
GDD r6 memory production very soon so as
a result I do predict that the GTX 1100
series will come out by the end of this
year but maybe not in August I would say
maybe in September or October at the
very latest if not August but I doubt me
Nvidia would want to miss out on the
holiday season of 2018 as for the
release schedule I'm pretty sure that in
video will stagger their releases once
again so we can expect the gtx 1180 and
1170 to come out in August through
October of this year and then the GTX
1160 and 1180 will probably come out at
the end of this year like December or
the very beginning of next year like
January to March finally some other
cards like the gtx 1180 TI and 1150 TI
will come up later on in 2019 so back to
the main question of the video should
you wait or buy right now well if you're
considering to buy the gtx 980ti well
then i guess it really doesn't matter if
you wait or buy I think you should wait
a little bit longer and maybe trying to
get the gtx 1080 TI for a little bit
under MSRP but it really doesn't matter
because the gtx 1180 is going to offer
the same performance at pretty much the
same price and also you wouldn't have as
many options at least at lunch for
example you would have like aces and
EVGA and msi and all those third-party
card variants so really the only reason
that you would not buy the gtx 980ti
right now and wait for the gtx 1180
is if you don't really need the
performance upgrade right now and you
want to be on the newest architecture
but that's pretty much it for the gtx
980ti so what about lower level parts
well if you guys late don't need an
upgrade then I do recommend that you
guys wait because the performance
upgrade is pretty significant and you're
spending the same amount of money
anyways also if you're looking at
getting the 1060 and are considering
waiting for the eleven sixty then here's
something and considered you may not
actually have to wait all the way until
the release after eleven sixteen to get
a performance upgrade when the 1170 and
eleven eighty come out the ten seven in
1080 will most likely drop in price this
may enable you guys to afford the 1070
which is pretty much the same as at
eleven sixty so that may be something to
consider as well so that's pretty much
it for considering the gtx 980ti and you
might want to wait for the 1180 then
really the only reason to wait is if you
want to be on the architecture for lower
level cards I definitely recommend you
guys wait if you don't need an upgrade
but it's really not that big of a deal
so what do you guys think do you guys
think that it's worth waiting for the
gtx 1180 also what do you think amy has
in store with AMD navi do you think it's
worth waiting for that make sure to
comment down below what you guys think
because I can read all my comments and
I'm accuse as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like this video then make sure
to drop a like on it and subscribe if
you'd like to see more videos just like
this one
but until next time bye
[Music]